[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sell
israels ich habe ja oft entscheiden
lassen was ist heute zu bereiten
wer fritz
er hat sich tornados gewünscht tornado
portal das sind worte ich kartoffeln die
so geschnitten werden als spirale und
dann frittiert werden und ich habe mir
das kommen dass distanz echt nicht sein
so wenig das machen wir nicht also
gibt's noch einen leckeren dip dazu
nämlich einen käse tipp und wir machen
daraus chili cheese
richtig gut und ich mache hier gerne
diesen frühstücks tipp den ich immer
samstags sonntags was uns sonntags mit
den kindern zubereitet und den habe ich
jetzt so ein bisschen abgewandelt und
das kommt noch dazu also bereit mir
jetzt erstmal den zu ich verwende dafür
200 gramm sahne 200 gramm käse da mich
jetzt einfach schafskäse und sohn gouda
zwei esslöffel mehl etwas curry kurkuma
pfeffer und am ende gibt's so die
eingelegten peperoni hier perfekt also
zuerst einmal sahne aufkochen
den käse habe ich jetzt auch schon
geschrieben
wobei er braucht die sahne nicht auf
kochen ihr könnt einfach alles verrühren
[Musik]
alles hier rein
ihr könnte auch echt perfekt einfach
käse reste verarbeiten
sonst schön kochen lassen und inzwischen
kann ich schon mal mich um die
kartoffeln kümmern ich lebe jetzt hier
relativ kleine kartoffeln die sind schon
gewaschen und die schale bleibt dran
dann kommt da ein schaschlikspieß rein
auf das und dass ihr euch nicht verletzt
jetzt setzt er mit dem messer hier oben
an mit einem kleinen und macht so
kleinschmidt bewegungen also einmal
drumherum nicht absetzen
und dann entsteht eine spirale
[Musik]
und wenn alles richtig ist könnte sie
jetzt auseinander ziehen
und sie bleibt und einem stück und
ich habe auch schon mal frites hier
fährt jetzt aufgesetzt leider passt das
ticken nicht immer eine friteuse sonst
hätte ich es einfach in der friteuse
frittiert könnte aber auch für eine
light-version jetzt einfach schön mit öl
bepinseln oder mit backt rendsburg
einsprühen dann ein bisschen gewürze
drauf und dann im ofen backen bei
heißluft oder bei umluft killen da
werden sie auch schön crunchy aber muss
schon dazusagen frittieren ist schon so
da bekommt ihr sie richtig knusprig und
fertig
die lehrerin in mir sagt
dass ihr das bitte hier auf dem
schneidebrett schneiden sollte damit ihr
euch die finger nicht schneidet das
frage ich mich war dass die lehrerinnen
würde die mama in mir
am besten so schneiden und in der hand
damit euren zarten finger hier nichts
passiert
[Musik]
ihr könnt übrigens auch so einem spiel
an schneider nehmen da habe ich nämlich
auch ein dass schneidet ihr einfach an
der kartoffel oben und unten den deckel
weg beziehungsweise den boden weg und
dann könnt ihr nämlich ganz dünne
[Gelächter]
und dann könnt ihr nicht ganz dünne
spiralen schneiden kartoffeln abdeckung
boden
diese wachsen kartoffeln schief
geht eigentlich noch
die dienste einstellung
ja
die werden trump jr
bisschen schneller
ja wir können ja noch eine dicke dickere
strecke einstellen aber jetzt sind wir
mal hier nochmal bei unserer soße die
soße ist jetzt nämlich auch so weit dass
koch schön und da kommt jetzt mail dazu
je nach käsesorte kann sein dass er ein
oder zwei esslöffel braucht
fertig die ist fertig
das ging richtig schnell jetzt hole ich
das frittierfett hierher und das darf
jetzt ungefähr
180 grad haben und dann wird sie zitiert
[Musik]
die samira ist die immer so gern wenn
freizeit praxis also nicht dass wir da
immer sind aber in efteling gibt es die
europa park gibt es die im disneyland
gibt die die sind schon gut
[Musik]
ja wo jetzt die soße ich glaube ich gebe
noch ein bisschen paprika dazu damit so
ein bisschen ein hauch
dunkler wird
aha das hat jetzt gar nicht gesehen ja
egal wie
sehr
ich habe zufällig etwas passiert
was ich da ausgerechnet heute vorbei
ja
okay es war ein bisschen viel
paprikapulver hat man das gesehen arbeit
jetzt besser aus
auf den muss ich wohl dazu aber ich
finde das geld aus dem kokon ja ich weiß
es jetzt nur mehr
ich glaube der vag länger drin okay
die jetzt so ein bisschen salz pfeffer
ich hätte
ok ich im einsatz muss ich mich immer
gut ist sondern nur so viel es ist ein
werk aber schmeckt immer gut
dann da drauf und ich hab mir jetzt
gedacht einfach soße drüber und die
chilis also eigentlich wollte ich ja
harmlos aber wir hatten nur peperoni ich
glaube das ist legitim darf man sie
trotzdem calacanis nennen ich denke es
kommt
die nachricht heraus ist darüber
[Musik]
nicht vielleicht nicht schlecht herr
specht
aber ich würde gerne probieren aber ich
muss dann doch noch schon mal
kam wir werden uns auch echt so das
ganze aber guck mal bei mir ist nur
einer geschafft darauf zu bleiben ich
musste jetzt so ein bisschen hier ich
glaube besser ist wenn man es gibt ja
auch
gut ich dachte mir ich
ach so zischt es amtlich holt das
reinbeißen dafür tue ich mir sonst
entwickelt die seit wochen von dem
machen käsefondue kassel ein käse fondue
käse fondue und dann die dinger
frittieren und rein tippen
natürlich overload
mc hammer ich hab mich zum käsefondue
ein jahr ja ich glaub ich generell zu
jegliche feierlichkeit einzuladen ist
vielleicht gehen sie mal kuchen mit baby
vielleicht bringt sie mal gute laune
metz potato tornados
mit vielleicht ich finde das echt cool
von lecker aber zu wenig so einem
käsefondue eine friteuse hinstellen
dass die gäste mögen vielleicht nicht
mehr richtig gut
als mega mega watt ich bin überrascht
über den geschmack muss ich sagen ja ich
habe mist anders vorgestellt wie ich
[Musik]
muss sagen der tipp der schmeckt sehr
gut das ich hätte ihn aber gern mit
chatter gemacht käse ist schon gut
gotha
wer wirklich erklärt ein bisschen wird
sega kam auf jeden fall machen weil ich
das ist gut so kitschig aber mit ja
genau kann ein stärkerer co finde ich
auch nähe doch aber von der gleichen
studie neu und kamen durch ist du kannst
das nicht kann nicht mehr ich kann heute
nicht mehr wir haben heute schon mal was
passiert denn wir sind sparsame
frittierfett nutzer und wenn wir schon
mal frittieren dann frittieren war
gleich zwei drei verschiedene dinge
vielleicht morgen nochmal mit dem rest
weil
es halt wert ist gut
das ist gut so ich habe den heraus warum
auch immer zudem ist man noch fertig
freue mich gerade tonaufnahmen gemacht
ja genau ist gut und die hier werden wir
auch gleich noch frittieren und ich
glaube die sind original also ihr könnt
gerne auch dran bleiben und schauen wenn
wir die dann gleich noch verkosten weil
ich glaubte wenn richtig christi problem
wie die augen
und bleibt ob war ja unser lange nicht
mehr draußen und fotos machen die fotos
und dann die armee sehr lecker
[Musik]
hallo damit
platziert wird beim zitiert wird bin ich
zur stelle ich finde die show und
christen
aber ich muss dazu sagen ich glaube die
anderen sind zum essen west
java meine erste frage weißt wie wie
soll man die besten ohne sie kaputt zu
machen sich diese pommes chips überhaupt
die in der tüte
und ich habe mal
am rande sein das ist einfach nur fertig
los ist
soll nicht heißen dass es schlecht ist
ich habe matschiner kartenwerk macht der
akku aus fleisch mit türkischem joghurt
war und die dinger so obendrauf wow
einfach
löffel gabel messer tasse kaffee
und ich dachte jetzt ich mache mir so
ein paar frau und dann mit käse und so
ein bisschen wir mal mit dem tipp aber
ach die sind zwar cool aber die anderen
sind schon besser zum essen ok so ein
bisschen chaos im königshaus war aber
dass mit joghurt ist hammer
so
ich fange sich gleich wieder was
hast du sagt grad
das war 100 die theke gekickt es tut mir
leid aber
es ist
das wirklich mit gaze joghurt 10%
knoblauch salz pfeffer schaue wie lecker
ist
aber ich glaube aber ich plädiere dazu
wenn wir das noch mal machen
dann machen wir die eine nummer trägt
tracht gehört ein bisschen sauer
weil sie sind schon echt hammer ja aber
die sind so dünn und knusprig das
englische zerbrechen wenn man sich schon
etwas stellen die hand nimmt das stimmt
deswegen probiert gerne die tornados aus
ihrer teams wissen wir waren ja das
rezept gibt es wo
er bei sally
ja damals daraus her geklaut ok also
viel spaß machen
denn kopieren können wir gut
viel spaß beim nachmachen und bist du
dich nur
das mache ich ja jetzt
aber noch frittierfett was noch
frittieren
dekretieren jetzt sellerie
außerdem stehen noch unser video offen
mit ihr habe ich gekauft und jetzt steht
noch offen was wir kochen
lahmacun hatte ich ja gesagt
wahrscheinlich das weingut schritte
diskutiert mal nicht aber es ist schlimm
dass ich nach man schon mal gemacht habe
oder sagt ihr kommen mit mir zusammen
schreibt maria wollte dir nochmal machen
wollt ihr sehen wirklich damit dem opera
teig ausrollen und
stativ baby sondern nur wenige uni weg
genau die teile sicht des ksv
irgendwann anderes mal wieder vorbei bis
die tage
wie heute
jetzt muss die kirche wird geputzt und
seines feierabend
[Musik]